the last thing I remember was that we
were getting a Christmas tree and then
we bumped into some person it was a girl
wasn't it playing at the guitar so maybe
we didn't even finish episode 2 you may
be this this title is a lie tile is a
lie also hello Roman hello you rude
Terra man hello I see Mountain hello
Johnny Jones hello mantas and I think
you're not staying because you haven't
played once upon a time in a while
oh hi old world there were two old
brothers living in their home layer with
her Papa wolf they all lived happily
together but one day
want to stick their dad away forever so
now the brothers were alone and they had
to find a new home that's when the Big
Brother discovered that the little one
was not an ordinary wolf but a super
wolf and then they worked together to
learn how to use his power and to follow
the rules for the hunt they discovered a
secret hideout where they could train
day and night they were happy but the
Little Wolf got very sick so they had to
move on on the way a deadly predator
attacked them but they scared it away
they decided to journey to the home
other nearby ancestors to seek help
finally the tired and hungry brothers
made it to the home of their ancestors
the old wolves invited them to stay he
even took care of them they were happy
to have a safe warm place to rest the
Little Wolf even made friends with a
raccoon and together they went on
awesome adventures unfortunately the
hunters were hot on their trail and
found them but the old Wolves help the
brothers escape
oh yeah others had no word to stay again
so they decided to keep going south to
the distant homeland of their papa
okay yeah I remember now thanks for the
little recap that was very cute I like
how it's all done in the style of his
sketches because you know you can stop
for moments and sketch your environment
cute
[Music]
[Applause]
dream
where you can't get what you want
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for subscribing Gabriel
no way you little [__] Daniel get your
ass over here now he's sitting his sweet
smile oh brother used to steal my sweets
all the time it was so nice job buster
oh I was like why are we in a nice house
I thought we were just escaping okay
this makes senses it's three months
before why am I getting dumont eyes
because because of the song but you I
don't think you should play this game
without listen to the music it's like a
pivotal part of life is strange isn't it
ah look is the leak lamp [__] I can't
wait for the show with the whole crew
it's a volume levels okay for you guys
I'm guessing they are
oh wait I just I can't wait for this
[__] oh look he's got a little he's got
a weight bag no I was looking at the I
was looking at the little figurine that
would [__] kill me if he found this
better not find it
not a single school starts how did I get
like to talk me into this [__] someone
followed thank you for following oh
thank you for subscribing salut 74 he
was up for the reservoir dive tomorrow
pass her mic [__] he's going they're
going to dive in the reservoir look at
me
yeah you swipe left
was this coupon for Hilah keeps hooking
me up with birthday gifts she's more
excited than I am I think that's that's
the best type of friends the ones who
are excited about things that you don't
care so much [__]
but I got phone and party bills now I am
a 16 year old high school student with a
3.5 GPA I don't know what that means
oh he's a track runner
I and have experience with people and
registers
need to put on the patch I bought last
week what patch is that that's a lighter
am i stupid I can't see a patch I just
see some cool drawings all right I'm
just looking inside the bag fair enough
way to save your artwork Picasso time
for a new sketchbook it's a hot dog in a
banana
I love the attention to detail that goes
into all of these environments man
I suck at perspective I should take a
class we are our own worst critic I
think this is awesome
scored it at the skate park last week
now I need to sew it on
oh here's the patch okay well sew this
on scored it at the skate park left now
I need to sew it on can I can I do it
can I need to put on the patch I bought
last week how you're not picking it up
what's this chronicles are the basilisk
awesome
wait should we have a look at pretty
tired keep doing the same thing look at
what's on this can I see can I see it
last week
some reason I can't pick it up pet
thinks I'll stop skating if I get a car
when I turn 16
wrong
oh that's better but I want to play
[__] hide-and-seek oh he's got a
little dead mice so cute
I love it gift from lion 10 he'll never
got so close to proposing to her too bad
we didn't have a clue she hated all of
us who is that
Karen Diaz tortoise Sports Club why she
hate you
this thing is so cheap and ugly got
nipples I love it lays it so lucky Noah
lives downtown Alstead driving crazy
24/7 my brother's a little player like
me loves it oh no he's doing bad in
school
dad confiscated the play box after that
Daniel was a total rage ball what is he
making with all that crap superhero
outfits
doh yes Daniel told for bedtime stories
count this for a girl in the 8th grade
thought I'd chickened out cool
I used to play with these had a Larese
man I feel old tell me dude okay he's
not in here
look India oh that's my bedroom
nevermind
turn back around
see he wouldn't be in the bathroom
I wish I had more time to play
that's what summer school
yeah we think they're probably
sucks to be Daniel we can't bug me all
the time I would have been pissed if I
was there you know I didn't appreciate
you calling the cops on me and my
friends last week and it was late but it
was Saturday oh so this is the neighbors
because at the beginning you had like
that big fight with your neighbor and
then what happened like they were going
to attack your dad or your brother or
something oh man I should have played
this ages ago but they were doing
something bad and then it was like
self-defense and she brother come on and
use the sticker powers and well the
neighbors kind of dead now and then your
dad was blamed for it we didn't leave
those bottles in the gutter on purpose
instead you made a big show and got the
cops involved they even thought I stole
one of my own cars I'm glad my kids went
home to see this we're gonna have kids
then maybe act a bit more like an adult
at least let your neighbors know if
you're gonna have a party or maybe
invite them you know that'd be nice
maybe he's invisible now dad got in
trouble for his last barbecue I hope he
does it again so I can come this time
wait
wait was it his dad that did all that
that did this stuff I would have been
pissed if I was their [__] I don't
know
it was either the neighbor was dad
either way you should now [__] it I'm
now I'm like oh actually it's okay
because it's him could be anywhere
oh [__] it's gonna be outside it's me
what's
sorry Andrew I'm the free babysitter now
it's house bit messy
Daniel is psyched but I'd rather just
told live on the crew you can even fish
from the deck
okay listen here
whoa hold on dude I told you to stay out
of my room oh yeah I'm not [__]
around anymore
got it do you hear me Daniel you shall
not enter your brother's room watch out
man
you started it dicken what is this crap
are you fighting again
you're proud of yourself stop it enough
getting tired of this Shawn what
happened now dad I told him not to come
into my van he never listens to me I
brought the tree he's lying he always
just that when he gets busted little
enough you both better listen because
I'm tired of this crap okay this is my
house too not your playground you hear
me jeez
you guys are working my last nerve this
week you okay me home I'm going to talk
with your brother
you know the drill I didn't do anything
let's talk oh this is so stupid it's
[__] you done hmm whatever like
you're gonna believe me
Daniel's always right look please
listen Shawn I can't do this on my own
look some tiny thing you can't I need
you to help me I know you don't want a
babysit Daniel you grow up you need
space more freedom I get it but we're a
trio now and you gotta take some
responsibility that little [__] it's
just a kid you're almost an adult I know
I know that and I do looked out for him
I swear but he's a little brat so were
you and you had eight years of being
spoiled before you had to share toys
with your little brother I know it might
sound cheesy but we have to be good role
models for him he's a Diaz right
okay I hear you I'll try to be super bro
just try to be there for him like you
are now it says mijo I'm late for work
go talk to your brother and work this
drama out
well go to the movies tonight a few guys
don't wreck the house I know you love to
hear this but I'm proud of you
both of you okay let's get to work
let's go apology well yeah let's go
Felicia I know I is because I'm an older
sibling so can I throw on my patch yet I
just want to do this why talk about it
my gun - it's so annoying where did he
even come from anyway see in O in there
did he come from here you see in the
closet I don't know where he came from
I better do something about Daniel yeah
yeah can I come in
it's the big bad no I said nope get out
double standards I'm not listening
[Music]
oh don't know who drew this but it's
totally red hey Daniel why are you
powering a young space warrior should
never pout
we need to stand strong against the
enemy come on man
I'm running out of punchlines here leave
me alone
No so we use it was doctrine stuff the
alien toy oh she kept this guy we got
him from that creepy circus remember you
wanted him so bad
got him for you shooting at that
freaking target Yeah right dad aim the
gun so what he's still one because of me
why are you still here
hey that's cool did you make it no it's
fracking problem
wait hmm okay if I sit down
so when did you get this last month dad
said I should learn the new stuff by
myself since you're not around as much
hey come on it's not like I'm leaving
home
you might as well I never see we don't
even play games anymore
we don't do anything Daniel I just I
want to hang out with my friends
sometimes you'd kind of be doing the
same thing in a couple of years hi I
don't want to grow up it me neither
here
sorry I took it that's what you wanted
oh that's stupid watch you said you'd
give me one at the thrift store last
week but you forgot like before well you
better keep this watch then well
thanks Sean this is so cool oh is it
gonna cut back to present I'll keep it
forever and ever like looking as watch
or something I'll keep it forever is it
is it is
there it is Oh cute he's made the ten
his own with those little sketches
I'm gonna pick I haven't a feeling most
grown-ups don't want to grow up
mm-hmm you don't have to grow up that's
the secret just don't I mean you do
physically but you don't have to
mentally
wait did they have a talk I know whose
dog this is I think that would freak me
out
oh he's got some picture of his dad
behind him that's so cute
this has gone on shaggy
[Music]
Beavercreek feels so far away what is it
though it's just a snowman
magic scroll what do you use it
what a creepy demon blonde
[Music]
oh cool
what's this no sign 50 miles away plaza
forest so this is where we're going no
way I can commute there every day went
dumpster diving nearest supermarket
jackpot crazy how much good stuff they
throw away quite a lot of stuff there
No
Daniel's okay but he broke some stuff
around the house trying to use his power
to try to help him control at the house
you mean the tent well they do have a
dog
oh that's back when they did
that's cool that's so cool I love that
donas please we had to leave I don't
like it either
if we stayed no way the cops would just
let Claire and Steven take care of us
they would have Hank up her ass into a
police car but what if they would
believe us so over this [__] what are
they going they're going to put the LA
bus he loves the trained homeless again
no wolf
a lot of missing persons posters
crazy
he doesn't talk about it but
I know Daniel really misses Chris Daniel
keeps reading it again and again mom dad
I have no idea but I do know Shawn and
Dan you're innocent
you'd the only family be a blaster
please help my boys if they come to you
oh yeah because it's from their mum um
we don't we don't really know why she
left but she left for some reason right
you know because I think we read that
letter in the last playthrough as well
another month and we'll be hooked up for
in Mexico oh we have a lot of money
still can't believe we ran into the guys
again talk about [__] fate yeah so
that with the mmm the other like
homeless troop now yep I'm a real man
now got a raisin she says no barity
pubes okay
everybody ended up at a good sleep oh hi
yeah yeah I did
Thanks nice okay breathing it better hit
the shower before they use all the water
all right
see you around
because they were all on remember when
they sure left be very stern in the
Train and they were all on the carriage
that girl is even more a sleepyhead than
I am all these trees I do love these
trees ancient and majestic
[Music]
never seen a dog so chill doesn't care
about anything yeah like you don't get
pet enough around here
did you see all that fog earlier creeps
me out
I don't know what's inside like that
movie
don't do this again gotta remember how
to draw no no don't do that
wait wait wait oh yeah go to look up
first too much again I'll get him up
before a big Joe gets here
good I want you to start you are so
yellow cool I think I'm ready to draw
this
these trees are just so gorgeous
time to take the pan dude
you have to move your mouse around so
much better this pretty good but I can
add more details if I want okay got it
oh here we go now it's coming together
more
I've looked enough times you draw now
that's nice
okay let's go talk to our friends oh my
god wait - cha cha grass I missed it
show airs down yes exactly
you hear that I heard nothing penny hmm
maybe it was the coffee brewer nevermind
you can't hear only me I don't
understand
why are you miss all those insects how
the [__] the swarm is coming you mean
bugs I haven't seen any flying bugs not
in the winter least sure sure
gnarrk stealth drones all this [__] wait
up boy look up you saw them when how
because visions aren't they watching us
now that would be [__] for me and
understood is the job the cash is good
for us to travel wait are they getting
paranoid are they actually seeing like
cops and stuff
oh hey pea study hey how how works so
then where's your next pit stop we want
to see all the Cowboys in Austin but we
spend too much money so far
traveling is expensive the pairs are you
trouble for me look at us
cush yeah not when they legalize that
[__] then you can work legal on the farm
right side up the government steps in
then the pigs pill pushers all bad
it's legal in Washington and it's worked
out okay it's gonna be legal everywhere
soon anyway legal but control weed the
[__] hey freedom I don't know things
have to change
Oh
did anybody you see Daniel I haven't
seen him this morning I saw him walking
with Finn they were headed to the lake
thanks Ingrid I better see what he's up
to you tell him no swimming that Lake is
toxic man
yep
I'm up for some heavy barrel lifting
tonight because we know you wouldn't
hear waters kind of rare around here
everything goes into the plantations
yeah been working for three years in our
coffee shop to pay for most of em are
into fancy hippie fish and fast food
Jack good times
you forget son did I don't make some
more coffee right why wish we came
sooner I feel like we will never see
everything now he keeps moving a pen I
think I knew the world was right
you saw it a real choice guys sure know
how to live outdoors it taught me so
much already so he wants another coffee
I am your coffee slave oh sorry my bad
yeah nacho coffee boy we surely always
- I made it
take some give some it's only fair okay
I guess he can get it himself I'm not
that much of a slave
I guess cuz I had some of the one that
he brewed I brew one for him funny I
like being out of that forest now my
hatch in the head I would have killed
for something like this back in that
freezing house in Oregon
hey like in the game it's good as always
life is strange you can't go wrong nice
and chill I mean everybody just stop
playing again after quite a while let's
go lots of death birds around the camp I
think we here at souvenir for a weird
place
you can wash it in the toxic lake what's
the date today is it the 15th or 16th
my turn got a stock up the shower in
kitchen later tonight
can I bet you again
we should rain more nice to get fresh
free water I wish I could send her a
cool gift
what's up Jake hey Shawn not much what
do you got going on me this is a
birthday card for my little sister don't
laugh
oh that's cute how old is she she's 9
years old now
like Daniel do you miss her
I probably miss her the most I'm kind of
jealous you get to hang out with your
brother all the time but I bet it's hard
to be his brother and father figure
that's my job now
full-time Daniel Wrangler he's really
lucky to have you hey since you're such
a pro big bro what's a good way to end
this letter goodbye
sounds a bit lame right well what is she
into like anime or video games puppies
she has a pet chicken named Alexander
Sara loves that thing but it creeps me
out why not draw a creepy portrait of
Alexander good idea it'll match my
chicken scratch perfectly anyway thanks
for your help Sean I got to finish this
before I get ready for work don't want
to be later big Joey you and me both
Sean thanks again Jake stuff is always
so tidy and neat just like him I
wouldn't know what happens all these
people were they out here
these guys have top gear I wish I do
okay I know I suppose we go into the
lake but I feel like there's still so
much to explore who's Hannah oh that's
like I'm so private about her life plus
she probably hates my guts
why is that the girl that was a day in
the guitar not quite sure who penny is
he's so out there
when she went to the lake as well what's
down here
you better check on Danny okay
Canton game is like nope
but the signs they kind of have backup
signs jeez she's way messier than me hey
don't judge it's hard to believe
it's a mystery how thin can be so messy
and strong at the same time
kind of a backhanded compliment Oh glad
somebody's getting some action
none of the Flies always bought in
reading in the morning like he isn't
cool enough already
wait should I write to see somebody has
fins back thanks to the Coast Guard Bob
I always wanted to see more of the
country I never thought for this war but
after 20 years of Pio I've seen too many
kids tossed in out of the system we
don't care about where they're going
after they've served time but that's
what we should care about the most we
didn't get along at our first meeting as
I'm sure you remember but I knew I had
to prove I was willing to help you
before you would trust me
I wasn't sure that would happen don't
laugh but I love being proved wrong I
needed it you showed me that on the
other side of your pain and anger you
wanted to learn and help others who feel
alone in the world without friends or
support I'm glad to see you've found a
group you can trust and travel with I do
hope you find a place to settle in and
call your home I know you will things
are a little tougher in the world then
when I was your age where every
generation has to go through their own
BS trials I'm proud you're willing to
practice what you preach I hope this
letter finds you well and I can't wait
to read about your next adventure so
don't make this old sob wait too long
that's cute I feel ready nosy here Finn
told me a bit more about train hopping
this map is like his Bible
weird to see him younger he looks so
innocent I thought I'd like to eat but
his guys in a whole nother level can't
tag a train without paint
okay so I think Matt's master the shower
you can have a shower
oh the toilets we can go for a piss
toilet then large and humbling I mean
it's better than going out in the world
isn't it we shower like once or twice a
week gives us more time to chill right
smell so many missing persons around
here creepy
we went swimming there a couple babies
I'll find out their backstory it's
[__] awesome
okay let's go to the lake
what the wait is he showing him his
power is he supposed to be no I [__]
rule that was dope what's up guys
morning target practice six bull's-eyes
in a row kid is a [__] ninja hey we
didn't want to wake your sleepy ass up
yeah
thank you for that you okay Daniel hey
seriously I've never seen anyone throw
like that I mean he has to learn where
we're on the run so Wow
been trained you well six full-size dude
yeah I got better luck you can't throw a
baseball without hitting me in the nuts
how did you learn to aim so good
practice Yeah right
why what's up with you two I should have
let you know but I'm watching him like a
hawk seriously yes respect he's right
now you ain't not that I'm as hot or
cool as his big bro yo Shawn idea I want
to see if Daniel inherited the family
blade skills from you I've gotta be I
get it how about a little bit oh it was
my turn come on let's give the man a
chance okay yeah I'll take a shot I feel
like the game is judging me on whatever
I do nice
I don't want to I don't give in to peer
pressure my party I do okay
oh [__] this is hard oh right
oh I see
oh this is hard
hold your right arm more like this
better alignment better a won't really
help dude what's wrong with you
this guy is bringing out the worst and
them to it I don't like it
let's show the kid was freaking timing
I'm trying to get used to the timing
come on Shawn show us your talents
got a hit between the [__] eyes damn
oh oh did you guys escape from some
circus hmm I was just luck
seriously that [__] was off the chain
one time is luck second time okay
one one one one one one [__] oh [__]
that
wait where is it go see I brought yeah
where'd it go
sorry Shawn you're not a ninja it's
still cool just ask your brother for
help next time yeah what would I do
without him after that workout I need
some more [__] Java wait don't go yet
oh it's so good Daniel we can practice
later yeah if it's cool with hey big
brother
yeah love you man no I don't like funny
what [__] stop acting stupid
oh I'm annoyed because he was usually in
front of Finn not stupid he won't find
out you don't know that you're gonna get
busted and I know you need to listen to
me stop calling me that I'm not a kid
anymore
Daniel don't why see stop Daniel now or
what I said stop you're the mom come on
won't be seen the mom sure I'm sorry I
didn't mean to I'm okay
it's fine I told you you're good but you
don't have control over your powers yet
yeah but we stopped ringing since we got
here you'd rather not what their new
friends well because we need to fit in
if we want to keep that job okay but
you're right yeah that's true he's
getting high let's do some training
later today cool
yeah let's go by the late again but Sean
how long are we gonna stay here it's
been like a month I know saving up money
our money to get to port the lows
remember it's time take forever you
should try and find mom since we have
her let her know you know I'm not gonna
be mean I mean we've already had this
conversation
sorry Daniel oh we can't we don't even
know where Karen really is and we can't
risk getting caught we're looking for
her she's one of the reasons we're out
here that's why we're going down to
Mexico how come I never get to choose
I'm the one with the power
I hear you it's not fair but sure my
brother my responsibility I have to take
care of you I know I'm not gonna be a
kid forever Finn treats me like an adult
he understands Dana doesn't have that
responsibility of taking care of you
Jesus Christ Oh Oh Big Joe who's Big Joe
was Big Joe wait what happened to the
watch is the watch gone yeah what do we
do should we ask about the watch sure we
see nothing should we ask what the watch
should we say nothing what do you guys
want to do you tell me cuz I don't know
I kind of missed that I was too busy
looking at the scratches on his arm I
did I didn't see was there a watch there
was there not I don't know
I'm waiting I'm waiting for you guys -
grease hi I cannot pronounce your name
sir I won't even driver hi
welcome I love lag
waiting waiting to hear what you said
did anyone see was he wearing to watch
no I was just looking at the scratches
on his arms I think I'll just ask I
think I just asked about it please Terry
didn't see either
shall I shall I
[Music]
okay I'll ask hey you don't wear your
watch anymore
what Oh No
I put this on instead Finn gave it to me
Oh
pretty cool huh Wow yeah pretty cool hey
Daniel that hurts
remember what I said low profile
yeah okay we're cool I don't like
working on a farm I know a trippy way
worse we're making Kashi not okay
well Daniel when we're safe and far away
I know I have fun playing hide-and-seek
last night
especially in the dark
that was cool thought penny might hide
forever yeah well we said the trees were
off-limits cheater
hmm wait
this is writing camp hasn't killed us
but legalization will smell Farms you
have to stay in
in small farms so is it illegal to work
on the farms
is that what I'm talking about that's
crazy well was it just because you have
to sign some documents or like the
American citizen or something cuz then
they haven't crossed the border yeah
see it here my man I need a bodyguard
like you cool tell Shawn an EMS
oh I don't like this boy I mean I like
my brother but I don't like this other
dreadlock dude
mind if I sit here sure
why so serious nothing just thinking
cool I'm always worried about my city
boy everyone here this isn't a [__]
School Bus late
I wanted to go to the lay no captain no
capitalism will crush the smaller
companies by flooding the market with
hundreds of bigger farms or that's what
I think in my event oh okay that makes
sense
that makes sense
I have family in Wales that have a farm
a little bit so at this point a liar
dude whatever just anymore boots you
know yeah I don't bother you
some gutter Punk jump you're not
listening to anything I say are you yes
I am two peas in a pod these ones
oh wait how did you get out of that
smart they have to get too clingy people
run away I know what I'm talking about
so how do you feel who knew this little
tree market snowflake could end up here
that's misfit
turning into a dirty jefe I actually
feel really long time enemy had a bet
how long I'm gonna shut the [__] up back
there I can't hear my music guess what
he was on his secret Sat phone again
this morning
speaking Romanian and [__] oh here it
comes
he's agent 420 and he has a license to
cook um what's that told you a thousand
times Big Joe is a colorful they come
from the factory of Silicon Valley maybe
he's just the factory reject let's be 9k
just don't be so mean it's right there
Oh Shawn are you crushing on big Joseph
oh that is so Shawn let's be Joe
Shawn loves me Joe you're all in love
with Big Joe you can't stop talking
about him I swear but his ass is too big
enjoy the cieariy for a change
now I'm the laughingstock to everyone
not to me
yeah I agreed someone on it ik
I'm not a massive fan of any other size
yeah me too
let's try to go to me
yes please and no week
for another great day
I'm so [__] tired
stop your bitching or get out of here
hey okay this is not a good job no
wonder they were all taking the piss off
it means me yeah I mean hey come on
that's not cool are you really [__]
talking me Cheech forget it Shawn
seriously boy we're late
hey you're gonna get us kicked out of
here well I just wanted to what be a
white knight
I can take care of myself Shawn bro that
guy would have beat you down maybe
that's what he wants
hey Kelly thanks but too late the lag
got in the way
oh thanks for coming I'm not your way
right no no we're sorry we we just you
don't get paid to be late next time you
won't be listen up I need two teams
today Finn penny Anders and what your
name will clean up the mess from the
storm the rest of you get to sit and
trim like I want to go pick up a bunch
of [__] all over the camp hey you want
to trade places
shut up Daniel you got a deal kid yeah I
get to go outside Hey
you guys still don't get it this is work
not a goddamn summer camp you're not
special there are dozens of hippies like
yourselves begging for work at the next
town kid your dad should teach you to
shut your mouth
oh do you not talk about that dog then
you better watch your guys of course
boss no problem
wait does he think his brother's his dad
okay so move it yeah you heard the man
stop [__] around and get in your
team's all right hold up you and me are
gonna talk
remember I'm only letting you and your
brother work here because Finn put in a
good word I know we're really
appreciated Thanks yeah yeah no
ass-kissing please just watch out next
time you brother [__] up
you're both God oh but this is a pot
farmer he's a [__] kid
you hear me no ass-kissing got it Oh
keep him out of the way you better this
business has enough [__] already right
I'm gonna go check on him then how old
is he anyway
Oh nine he's nine years old
jeez tough age gotta keep a close eye on
him
he seems oddly nice not my business but
you got kids yeah
her daughter 12 years old do you do you
get to see her not often but she needs
the money I get out here okay
I'm not your buddy get the [__] out of
here you got a lot of work to do today
all right huh thank you
that was weird
like we are bonded Oh
Hey okay now for the fun part I need
this all done by tonight no excuses so
get on it all right we good finished
playing boss with his crew I told him
that all work late if they didn't finish
on time I hope so okay I got to make
some calls
well what are you waiting for you know
the drill
what such ass I feel like I'm in prison
it's black I hear you but we're not this
is just our job man we have to follow
Merrill's rules now especially you what
do you mean you're interested to have
you kids around here
so don't give him any excuse to get
pissed off hey never know with Merrill
he can be cool but scary when he loses
his [__] okay jeez not doing anything
bad I know I know I know you guys are
having the time of your life here but
I'm not so shut your mouth and give me
some quiet for [__] sake okay well why
do you stick around then none of your
damn business but I'd be long gone if I
had the chance
trust me all right man
just pick a bud and get to it
all right guys this is how we make the
weeds pick it up from the pile this game
is so edgy oh damn it
wait am I sure it's dominant yeah I hate
these scissors
wait Oh am I supposed to wait until this
in our case I have to work the perfect
timing
gotcha I think
whoo-hoo one down just a bazillion more
to go
welcome to the game where we make
cookies but no this is nothing a spring
we were determined about two or three
pounds a day
whoa that's a lot yep had to work
overnight all the time 15 hours straight
once yeah trying to forget I was done
with Kosh after that oh we are lucky
right and then your arms fall off [__]
all that
yes
do you get any reception Big Joe just
bless you clean my scissors they're a
mess
wait just let me get this done never
seen such a way yeah we'd like a bro you
know I'm I'm a cool kid I know how to do
thing ad ad you okay sweetie it's okay
you're doing fine
just slow down if you need to
I know I would Thank You Shawn it feels
nice being a nice brother see I might
not be the cool brother at least I'm
Carrie hello
he's not working anymore he stopped his
game he's just had a little rest my ass
hurts
[__] this is really boring oh poor baby
that's the job don't think just work
okay well you can't think it was don't
ask me to smile for the camera all day
long
feels like working in a factory imagine
doing this for years
see Sean agrees with me as always this
is fun at first but it does start to get
old after a while
how about stop bitching so much Sean
you're already on Merrill [__] list
don't get us all kicked out of here just
sit in trim yeah I know damn song we
really need to do something about your
hair what what what's wrong with my hair
are you kidding middle shot hide in your
pretty face I can't allow that come on
it's not that bad just just a mess yes I
worry not
we've got everything to take care of it
advocate so we have we'll see
going too fast
take your time I don't know how many
you've got to do I don't know if I can
put a litt for real although if you
could snap your fingers and go anywhere
cassadee we get it over and over you
don't want to be here so what so I'm
allowed to dream a little you won't get
hurt
promise what about louisiana must be so
sweet this time of year come on
dream big I'd like to see the pyramids
or the top of Mount Fuji Shan Diaz
Global Traveler yeah
stalking Humboldt no [__] [__] [__]
nobody's making you babies work here
mm-hmm
you guys are all the same cool let's be
trimming grants then you barely work for
a month this is my life [__] it's always
something right why can I get what's
this
can you folks put a lid on it we got
[__] to do here whoa whoa down easy for
you to say cowgirl some of us have to
work please I bust my ass like everybody
else
uh-huh don't even you're always looking
for an excuse whoo it's 4/20 hey Sean
nice duck oh my arm hurts
Wow Wow get off my crack two months I
didn't come out to California to live on
a [__] farm I want to see some water
are we gonna squat out here forever
build a house
what stop you know we voted to stay for
a while
once it's legal we ain't got no more job
here oh so that's what they're wrong
about legalization is that I'm just over
this place then go take the [__] off if
we're a family
we stick together you're on the bus
we're off the bus
oops thanks mom anything else yeah but
we don't have the time did you fall out
of the wrong side of the tent or what
what's position
[__] this [__] hey nice I know
hey I don't want to fight been a long
crap people just keep it [__] down in
here okay edge lord the game yep wonder
why we got the pen maybe four so we
control around here maybe we didn't have
thanks we had a pen back at camp
so maybe we can draw here
hey it's me tree
Jaxson
cheer up my little Shawn trust me it's
not as bad as you think other farms in
the areas just straight down exploit
your ass you got to be careful of those
scissors they're sharp as but yeah no
[__] oh you'll get scars but you'll get
it part of the fun and sex here later
Big Joe smile [__]
so did you have a good day at work honey
[Music]
I do mini clash love the Jerry Springer
moment when Hannah and cast started
picking on each other yeah they love to
start [__] with each other then get high
short-term memory loss
how was your day did you have fun
outside nope
picked up branches and [__] got covered
in mud would not recommend still sounds
better than sitting on your ass all day
I feel you Sean as always that's why
you're such a good fit for the family
you totally hooked us up good job cash
everybody's cool with you too Daniel is
your secret weapon I don't know he's way
too young for this [__] you gotta be
Zen
the more you try and control him the
less you have deep huh swear he acts
just like me
that's how I know he's smart and he's
also got a kick-ass nerado
yeah my brothers are like that so what's
your story I mean you don't have to tell
me yeah I was pretty lucky my parents
were okay
I had three big brothers you spoiled me
huh you were the baby boy like Daniel
but my family was kind of mm-hmm mister
my dad was like a front for hot cars
yeah he'd steal stripped and sell them
my brothers and I helped him you know
typical [__] too we got busted [__]
feds wanted me and my brothers to
testify but my dad narc done us instead
Anthony
that sucks wow what happened I went to
jail when I got out I was like [__]
everybody so I hit the road jack anyway
I found a cooler favour out here you
know I love traveling
check it out new things interesting
tonight never gets old
I guess caring going to Mexico is the
ultimate road trip if we make it there
dude who knows it's pretty scary so
[__] far hey it is but you have time
and a strong good mind will ya nothing
could stop you from going there thanks
baby boys are just what to say be
alright
therapy's over oh yeah I gotta move
those water teams for the shower and
stuff it's cool you're doing your part
huh I love talking but I can help
she thanked her guitar again
hey hola que estas Senor yeah me too
estas haciendo para la voz don't laugh
still learning
at least you're trying you never food
let me finish this new song before ever
did it don't let me get in the way talk
later
damn Shawn can you try and be less shy
sometimes
oh yeah let's take a picture of this
I mean draw a picture listen to her sing
[Music]
obviously Cassidy
cool I think I'm ready to draw this
I like how Cassidy's in her own world
when she's playing music hmm pretty good
but I can add more details if I want
time to take the pen dude oh man you are
so focused when you draw that's cute
yeah he just said the same things let me
be the judge whoa whoa give it back
please Cassidy do not even look Wow boy
really sure I didn't mean to freak stop
his tortured artist [__]
Sherrie come on [__] you're good
Wow I look happy
wax I've belong here I love how you see
me Sean I think I look cooler as a
sketch mm-hmm you think it's okay no I'm
just being nuts if it was bad you would
know I don't lie
well I could never draw like that what's
your secret I don't want to be too I
don't know I just get inspired by the
things I see and do and being around
people like you helps a lot so I'm like
their muse see wow you're a great model
yeah well don't make me blush we all
learn from each other right that's why I
love my life right now finally yeah but
we don't always have to suck up to
[__] like Merrill most of the year
it's just us the road and
what do you miss about your old life
anything besides some friends nothing
well my own bathroom out here you say
that you don't need all that [__]
they sell huh that's freedom
tricking this country is just to survive
I guess I do like traveling around but I
want a base will you ever go back to
Texas no [__] way
my daddy was a meth head who beat the
[__] out of my boyfriend just because he
wasn't white yep
been my big brother told me he would
shoot me if I dated dated that well you
know my mom didn't say squat as usual
thanks mom so [__] him oh this is my
family now damn
I'm sorry Cassidy ah don't be I feel
sorry for them so tell me what do you
miss about your old life hmm
from the unfriend well apart from my dad
I'd say Liza definitely she was like my
best friend and miss our talks I'm sure
she's very special
you didn't want to had a shitty day she
would always make me laugh always feels
like years since we talked probably
never again but things change right yep
so keep moving forward you have a good
heart
Sean I think you could use some alone
time see you later
I need to do some water buckets
okay it's good stuff
so Hanna how long ago did you come here
to Humble to work nine years
I love SantaFe because I want to hit no
money
nobody pitched north worked on farms
we're not a dream I had to bail after
some Tweaker tried to attack me up in
Arcata what that is awful Hanna I almost
killed that [__] but I came back to
Humboldt because of Finn got this sweet
deal with Meryl it's nicer here than
other places we saw too many junkies and
homeless may go together sometimes no
home get high what the [__] else you're
gonna do on the street
Julian it up we see so much trash for us
around here California's very green but
starting to look like [__] not everybody
has time to [__] recycle or compost
their [__] especially when you live off
the grid we all should try it's
everybody's planet to Sweden is not
perfect that we try to be more eco
conscious Liberty only have one planet
I'm Taurus talking [__] again like you
guys have it so hard we didn't help say
that we did tell me again how many hours
you spent on a plane we intend to become
crying about the whole birds in the
forest good point
now you're here sponging up an illegal
pot farm with the tourist visa lecturing
us funny right I mean we were not trying
to lecture you
we are grateful we found that job and
that's we'd like to stay in the camp
with you guys I know were cool
do you hate us now you're funny don't
worry
you know if I hated you all I care about
is my family right here these three
gutter punks the rest I used to peeling
potatoes huh a lot of work I know how to
cook just not everything yet yeah but
you hate it you want a pizza watch TV I
can tell like those kids who come
through here all psyched and they have
to bust ass and they're gone
like I have a [__] choice what am I
supposed to do maybe you chose this life
but I didn't I know I know
we all got scars of our own they're just
[__] hate ponies too many here Krusty
backpack doesn't make you one of us it's
not phony
he has my choice well let me just turn
back I gotta do to pass initiation don't
be a [__] stand up for us you can't be
part of our family unless you open up
this is a family - not a pit stop on the
wild sharing is caring
I turned it off my foot by accident
sharing is caring yeah I did the coffee
this morning I hear you but my brother
comes first always that's good Jose
you're not a selfish prick that way too
many
you don't have to tell me but how did
you end up on the road my community was
a mess too much wasted talent my mom she
was an artist and a drunk tried to get
her into rehab countless times little
bit work my ass off to buy her pinkie
stuff until I realized she was just
returning everything to Z Mart to get
the cash back to buy her booze I just
knew I had to get the [__] out he's
missing out or that curse I'm gonna get
me too I'm glad you're at peace now so
how did you hook up with the others met
fin had some squat when he got out of
jail young punk but old soul we just
clicked
then we ran into Cassidy a year ago his
dad everything her unable to commit to
anything except us then Pennywise found
us here and humble trippin about his
friend jinx but you know he just fit in
no we're all pretty [__] tight hell
yeah you are
it's awesome
so are you satisfied with your life now
I'm grateful for what I have
yeah not everything is perfect but we
got balanced prospects that's way more
than I had before thanks for taking the
time to talk Hannah that's cool yeah
anyway it didn't mean to grill you Shawn
it was a long day we're warm and
everyone up everyone up - Wow
- tough to figure out don't [__] with
her I think a sit here same but we can't
resist the Wonder lust plus Portland's
waiting for us tough to be so far away
from his sister he did the drawing
that's not cute I'm sorry I can't be
there to eat okay can open up for your
presents hope you had a fun party with
mom and dad and your friends can't wait
to see you again show you how cool all
my cool pictures of California I'll call
when I get a chance
me too I'm exhausted after two hmm
wonder who's her mom and who's the other
woman at some deep [__]
so cool he carries this around wish I
could see the pictures he took hello
down you're old
weird where did he get that from
so I guess we should ask them their
story oh no it's never mind I guess
they're just passing through citizen
tree masa
[Music]
we got this
once that let's get these over to the
kitchen and shower
I think I made some good trims today and
talking with the girls as always hey
Pete two more hands dish master oh wait
yeah I don't miss doing the dishes and
why are we doing to help out dad and all
that that's it finally need a hand with
your own chores thanks awesome
I need help moving the last water tank
this [__] is so heavy okay I'll wait for
you near the water tip so we can finish
your tour I'm already here dude
wait why isn't me helping us let's carry
that one to the shower
well I suppose suppress a different
button to have them help me
gotta put that one near the shower
where's the Ariela
you mind me rummaging through ten these
guys know how to make a bong out of
pretty much anything what is it and now
I do too nice to have a dog around again
it's still a nice room [__]
yes Penny's looking for somebody that
sucks
ah they look so cute here I love how
they're like a real family
wonder if they'd give me a cool nickname
if I stayed here anyone seen my face
okay so I don't know where the little
dude is gone but we did say that we're
gonna give punches his powers down by
the lake dam trimming is hard
how do these guys keep coming back
what up the usual carving some wood I
learned wood carving with an inuit
native back when I lived in Alaska it's
an antique technique helps me then I'll
focus you know I just let my hands
sculpt the wood and sometimes I have
good surprises I'm just kidding man it's
actually a cool cowboy thing I'm trying
to do for a while but I suck at this
it's just fun to relax okay
finn is to punk-rock to be a farmer
that's cool they let us use their extra
gear we look down
okay time to help Daniel do some power
training
I was really in the zone today hope that
okay
can you go up here nope
that looks a bit dangerous
easy money they said yeah right
hola just deny sweetie
but can you do it without your power oh
yeah
I can do better with my own skills now
next level
onward ready to rumble
[__] a do you want to used to berate
him from or used to pray you sir tell
not to swear now he's faring all the
time let's start with our team how des
levels
yeah we still sound okay no let's do
this come on
hold up
too many people over there let's hit the
other side
brass is very like see-through
does it have a material
okay so how do I do this
oh that's why you should've dumped I had
to throw down E
[Applause]
you know what you're doing hey your face
come on I wasn't gonna drop it on you
very funny man okay let's have some fun
mushrooms
hmm let's try this I want you to focus
on these ugly mushrooms and blow them
apart
dude I'll blow the [__] out of that he's
too cute if he's talking like that I'm
waiting
or maybe you what's up damn he is
getting strong tell you God can lift all
those I know I can
that's pretty
Oh Daniel that's uh that's amazing
come on find something else pick a rock
any rock okay and let's test your aiming
system this target in sight
locked and loaded awesome okay you're
good
now let's spice things up a bit
bring it on that was not a fair fight
that's right what's next
that was some next-level [__] Daniel
thanks I've been serious training on my
own sometimes I know I haven't been
around a lot lately
you still have to be careful with it man
always wanted both ways use it then
don't we just have to make sure you can
control it well it's my power not yours
whatever I don't want to swear him ask
me I don't want to say what's wrong with
you I just want to say are you trying
with you man you don't like this new emo
Daniel you keep throwing your attitude
at me for no reason
sick of it I mean I want to say cuz I
hang out with other people you're always
with them I'm a cassock - don't be so
jealous she's cool she what you hear
that's a he's a fish I know was way
better
hmm you don't know her I mean never mind
that's it enough
you're being a brat oh it's like
anything without you having a [__] we
still have a long way to go and we have
to go together right
I know it sucks but you have to grow up
now
[Music]
Daniel stop it
stop it Daniel is free now
don't go to the dark side put it down
that's pretty intense
I got serious munchies any chips left
dude you scarf the whole [__] bag
have another hit yeah yeah I packed the
fat ball
you're getting tired by oceans nice very
long devta leg ducks
[Music]
you see that [__] it's a [__] UFO
serious man look they're finally coming
to take you back
[Music]
he looks so nice I just really wanna go
comfy now
ready a new system
tripped on a few words but y'all are
baked so I'm good
good job sis so beautiful hey why are
you a rich and famous you can't hook us
up I love your voice thanks everyone
I take ass cash or grass hit him Shawn
take the puffs and pass it to your
friend no no I'm good
Daniel no [__] way
jeez I was just joking haha
you better be that is all for us we must
sleep ah there go the party animals what
is it like 10 o'clock no worry Finn
we were partying like rock stars
tomorrow for last night come on one more
round kind of tight jeez I swear every
time you play that song Cass I see my
poor black flag oh man I'm sorry who's
black flag it was my dog back in
Colorado until last year yeah something
like that a year ago we were hopping a
train just me
fandom Cass and Black Flag we got caught
stealing some [__] in some random town
[__] called the cops on us I
had to run for it
you saw that train from a farm we was
great at it cops are right behind us we
barely made it but nobody is able to get
black 5 Jesus yeah I see him chasing
after the Train yapping at me but I left
them there
that's that end of story I hope the cops
picked him up got him a better home I
can be wiping out him dog that every day
here's to Black Flag
that sucks Hanna we lost a dog to little
mushroom it's hard [__]
that's life so you got a walk-on
geez sorry I her in the mood don't worry
hands we can do worse let's hear
everybody's worst memory fair and square
he's serious why the [__] not
we all need to say our piece once in a
while who's up ready
cool huh stop the violence check this up
say hello to my little friend
chinks met him dumpster-diving a New
Mexico school boy had issue moose wings
hilarious self-harm fund [__] like that
that's how he met him i seem to be
better with me I think I love them gave
me this coin said he never gave his
trusted knowing before we used to come
here every now and then hook up on cash
but he disappeared a few miles north
from here in a pot farm just like this
one he went out one night highest [__]
his own that was the last time I saw now
I got a hold onto this [__] pinion
just in case
Jesus Christ that sucks brother [__]
like that happens right Blasi thing the
guy needed medication sure dude
I just hope he's okay maybe I'll run
into his crazy ass someday who knows
it's a small world I hand him back to
trust that he gave me all right bad
vibes indeed and will he do worse
Jake please well just don't laugh I
guess my worst memory is when I had lost
my faith what happened I used to be a
sheep a true believer I was raised in
Haven Point Nevada small community we
have this amazing Reverend people line
up to listen to her
she's intense but for some reason these
happened to me and I started doubting
myself it kind of escalated people said
I was trouble like couldn't get the
answers I was looking for even from my
own folks I know the feeling I felt so
lost this gaming was it real so I left I
just needed to be alone for a while you
know find the truth by myself I'm still
looking for it Jacob my son maybe we are
the truth you were looking for I'm glad
I found you guys I don't know if I'll
ever go back there not until I get a
signal from God at least I hope you can
write your family misses you a lot I
miss them too cutie just not the other
stuff
Oh what about University I don't choose
enough your turn yes I already saying
his own huh big yours what about you
Sean you obviously don't have to talk
about that [__] show back in Seattle but
if you have something else
yeah I know I've got a whole bag of
these don't worry we're all listening
man oh nice guy
I don't wanna behind well this is after
me and Daniel took off from Seattle last
year we ended up at this redneck gas
station in the middle of nowhere but our
pictures were on like every local
newspaper [__] gutter press so the
owner shows up oh he tied me up you call
the cops I hope you beat his racist ass
to a pulp actually Daniel did all the
work he got us out before the cops are
right oh that's much am lil ninja damn
vigilantes yeah life is a [__] you can
only go with the flow like a river
dragging around any bad memories come on
gold [__] oh you started this [__]
[__] don't Punk out no huh
listen smart asses I'm just saying you
can't change the past so you just gotta
focus on what's next
didn't he stop memories are just lessons
for the future the future huh what's
your big plan profit wanna know what my
plan is
picture this a kick-ass beach house in
Costa Rica sunshine feet in the sand
sweet ocean view we'd be one big
fucked-up happy dysfunctional family we
just chill and sing
drink cocktails out of coconuts only
thing we need is a little cash along the
way man oh jesus [__] christ that's
your dream beach house and coconuts Oh
too boring for you
this sounds like my folks retirement
planned in Florida
I don't need anything else then what we
already have not sure we're working our
asses right now but we can beat it if we
want I'm not gonna settle town no way
that's how it starts you know when you
start having things of your own things
you can defend property plant family
what do you think you're missing out on
now
coconut cocktails well agree to disagree
bucker
man I'm too high for your [__] it's time
to crash and penny goes down he's out
brother
hey night looks like we still have some
booze left your Zen Oh
twist my oh it's easy tiny drink and we
need to talk about Sean's hippie hair
boy needs a really good oh hell yes he
does
now it's your turn to get a trim karma
I'll call it a day to night everyone hey
I'm wiped out are you ready for bed yet
Oh
I think I want to get a haircut but also
I think we should go it down you're
right because he keeps saying that we
leave him alone all the time
so yeah I'm gonna go with that
Thank You anybody I'm ready to crash -
lets go
what no you're gonna miss our makeover
skills I'll fall asleep and then you'll
turn my ear off Oh get out of here see
you in the morning you didn't have to
come with me
you know I know
Hey
can we talk about what happened on the
lake yeah
I kind of bummed me out when you said
that you weren't a kid anymore I mean I
know you're not but I'm gonna miss it I
can't help it Sean things are so
different now miss my friends
I play BOTS everything thanks they
shouldn't it all seemed so far away
bucks I know I'm not always nice with
you but things aren't nice anymore I
know but don't let this change who you
are I just wish I could have a normal
life again
and stop being so angry all the time
you're just so tired of all this trap I
feel the same way dude it's okay just
don't feed the beast you know yeah
with that no let's watch I still like it
but it's kind of tight on me now yeah
you're too big for it I am wait but it
used to be how I would like to hear
about the wolf brothers how that's okay
just don't tell the others okay all
right get comfy we're worried oh yeah
the wolf brothers joined a pack of
hounds that roamed all over
finally the brothers had found new
friends but the little wolf wasn't so
sure about the new back he didn't want
his brother to run away with them and so
the little wolf would howl and prowl not
knowing what was going on but he didn't
know that nothing could ever separate
the wolf brothers from each other
ever
I wish I could fall asleep that quickly
that'd be great okay I do need to leave
I'm quite late but this is the thing
with life is strange just like you can't
leave mid episode but I do have to
uh-oh I'm late I even went to better
[Music]
no you couldn't hear me because the
music was too loud sorry I wasn't saying
much I was just talking about the epic
cinematic oh and I said it was too happy
so I something bad is about to happen
shortly okay this is boring
so everybody tell me how you're gonna
blow your next payday
the usual save it till the next one
oh well ain't we all stingy now okay
girlfriend for your family or or some
hookers or cocaine oh please there's a
child here I think he's our glorious
besides he's our mascot now oh I want to
buy a bacon burger and a pepperoni pizza
hmm then a lots of chuckle Chris and and
a red slushie hell yes screw the hookers
bring on the choco crisp come on John
you gotta treat yourself after all this
hard work yeah but we need to get to
Quetta love socks are a new toothbrush
oh I don't know socks new toothbrush
songs
okay that's silly but I really do need
another pair of socks I wash mine
overnight but they're not always dry the
next night he's got cold feet so that's
it huh you bust your ass all week for
nothing
some of us just got simple needs
princess yeah like your beach house in
Costa Rica yeah let's get this over with
Finn
Cassidy Sean and you
Jake Jake Jacob
Daniel dude do you have to do this every
week adults-only whatever I work - yes I
know we have to keep a low profile
got it for the millionth time just wait
here for a few minutes
don't do anything nothing I won't swear
okay we'll be right back what's wrong on
time let's see who wins that farm lotto
Jacob right I thought you wouldn't last
a day but you cleaned up you're all
right thank you
Thanks Cassidy your trims were pretty
weak and Big Joe told me you've been
whining a lot Betty did look you [__]
all you want as long as you work
otherwise you're just taking up space so
get it together
I know Merrill now for Shaun very nice
trims I didn't know kid then you saved
the pots in the greenhouse and our asses
that's why you keep coming back you know
it boss
how about a raise to cookie
sorry now for the moment you've all been
waiting for
what the [__] touch me jerk
don't move just stay outside
now explain that sneaky [__] he was
snooping around your living room no I
wasn't I was just bored so I came in oh
shut up Daniel seriously let it go I
told you
come on Meryl he's a kid not a thief
you wanna frisk him look at him he's
just following his big brother
your brother needs a lesson
you all need a lesson so first off
nope baby oh [__] baby oh don't do that
to us we earned that munch on you and
your brother are fired what don't come
back for Big Joe would take care of your
ass
please Merrill [__] man man I know
you're pissed but Shaun is a good worker
never brought you any losers right sir
quiet shut the [__] up Sean I warned you
one too many times we tried your way now
with my turn okay Joseph just teach him
a lesson
what do you mean
let me do come on man Big Joe what are
you gonna do he's just a little [__]
kid this ain't your business think I
like it
it's mine okay
okay who did that [__] who did that I
did my fault look I have to it's my
responsibility
does that mean died
Wow
oh there you go he's showing them all
now so everyone knows
well that's it believe it or not told
you it would sound crazy [__] that's
mental
exactly I knew something was up with you
guys man
I would be scared shitless
I am it's all going so fast I'm [__]
lost sometimes it's okay Shawn I know
what I'm doing man says Shawn
maybe this [__] is in your DNA - do you
have a superpower no zero nothing
trust me I try really to be drawing do
you have any idea where it comes from I
mean it can't be random reptilian I
think he turned into a reptilian or
something hey shut up I'm not of
reptiles her if Tilian not a reptile
it's not the same thing BAM they're so
unique Daniel that's why I need your
word that you'll keep all this to
yourself seriously
oh this stays right with us promise you
can trust us Jake I don't know I mean
this is a big deal Shawn how long can
you keep this a secret as long as we
have to it's all about keeping Daniel
safe it's my job now man what if he has
those powers for a reason maybe it's our
job to help him to guide him oh yes he's
religious Shawn dude no do not make this
into some cosmic [__] you still
can't tell anybody come on I wouldn't do
that to you Shawn or Daniel oh this
whole thing just blew my mind
I think I need a break
is that okay no worries it's cool oh not
after what you guys went through with
these bastards okay
talk later
he's right it's [__] [__] I know
Finn do you swear I mean it no worry
sweetheart
I'd never let anything happen to that
little guy he's a true rebel thanks man
for real
you battle Finn don't let me down uh
hold up you know no no there's a lot of
money around here
we're not using him oh no what the [__]
are you talking about Merrill's safe
it's like a [__] atm I've seen it
meet you in the back how you outlaws
gonna get the combination me no [__]
way Finn don't pull a kid into your
stupid [__] about getting a shitload of
cash isn't stupid we can get out of here
so you can be a beach bum you're so
selfish man how Sean and Daniel are out
of work they deserve this and ripping
Merrill off is the only way to do that
really and with a [__] kid you know
these [__] are armed right I guess I
didn't think about that yeah yeah no
[__]
don't lecture me
I was just having a brain fart let's
have a beer and forget about it Sean
cool I don't like not like I would let
you use Daniel anyway no more of this
crap
okay and I think the same so Milanovic
he just needs assessment that jakey guy
I think you did I can tell he was sorry
for him yeah damn I'm gonna drink the
crap out of this party so [__] you plus
since it's your last night time for your
tattoo that's it what are you getting a
tattoo no I'm done hipster we have other
things we gotta do mm-hmm okay guys I
definitely have to go now I know I
shouldn't have don't even to go at home
how does three more people know about
your exes date extra half-hour can trust
them and these voids get talking I know
but what if anyone gets scared you don't
know what can act so thanks so much for
watching I will carry on playing this
for you next week probably all the weeks
leading up to the Resident Evil release
I'm so freakin excited to play a
Resident Evil remake I'm getting that as
soon as it comes out and I'm going to
play it for you so until then we're
gonna carry on with life is strange so
have a lovely day or evening I'm gonna
say goodbye to the people that I can see
in the chat right now quickly before I
leave but you might have noticed I've
started to jiggle and that's because I
do need the toilet so I'll make this
quick goodbye
so Milanovic goodbye he's teddy
goodbye
oh wait is that it
Oh goodbye roll Briones and also hi and
goodbye virtual turtle games that's all
I can see in the recent chat anyway
anyone else I've missed I don't want to
miss anyone I think that's about it okay
goodbye to anyone who I can't see who is
watching and he was not in the chat
I appreciate or when's it coming out the
third I think I know for help the third
of next month is when worse and evil is
coming out but make sure you following
me on Twitter for more updates thanks
and you will be updated on when I stream
there is also a discord I don't have up
right now where's discord
let me do the discord
my naive the toilet just go ahead
actually I think it's in the I think
it's in a description should be in the
description well I'm getting out not
even ah there we go
so you can join the discord here anyway
goodbye Nikki Gaurav goodbye - let's
tell us why and you can find anyone else
who is watching who I haven't had a
chance to say goodbye to yet I will see
you next Thursday so yeah have a dear